wo ist denn die mauer wer glück hat
entdeckt das metallband das ihren
früheren verlauf markiert aber die mauer
selbst wer von den vielen
berlin-touristen findet die auf anhieb
nein da gibt es noch beiderseits der
ehemaligen grenze ist die stadt
gewachsen zusammengewachsen nur
alteingesessene berliner wissen wo sie
war
hinter mir und da ist sie doch noch
wenigstens ein paar meter mauer mitten
in berlin
original oder künstlich nachempfunden
als eiserner vorhang den beton der die
welt teilte einmal anfassen für
touristen wie diesen california ein
echtes erlebnis
ich hatte sie mir größer vorgestellt
andererseits ist sie extrem solide und
ich wundere mich dass sie immer noch da
ist
die übrig gebliebene mauer ist ein
touristen hotspot täglich gibt es
geführte touren
wir kontrollierten grenztruppen am ende
1989 waren es 12.000 mann und wachtürme
gab es alle 200 bis 400 meter und der
eine der noch steht ist ein beliebtes
foto motiv ansonsten müssen die
touristenführer eben viel erzählen von
früher über einen teil der stadt den es
nicht mehr gibt also spuren findet man
ja dann doch noch hier das heißt man
kann auch hier noch ganz gut sagen
zeigen die die stadt verändert hat was
das für den menschen bedeutet die hier
gelebt haben berlin neulinge sind ohne
guide häufig als vergebliche mauer
sucher unterwegs
keine ahnung wir sind gerade an der
regierung ist eine mauer
aber ich glaube nicht dass das die mauer
ist doch auch diese graffiti wand war
einst teil des sogenannten
antifaschistischen schutzwalls
allerdings von den einstmals 160
kilometern sind 150 verschwunden
eine grenze weniger